had a good time and the wedding singer
dude let's get back to the wedding thing
you're good this guy first of all oh
walks up to me before the dinner drops
and i'm like why right because the band
isn't playing yet we just [ __ ] all
got done crying we sat down at the long
table because we sit with our friends we
don't do that [ __ ] [ __ ] honeymoon
table what do they call it a [ __ ] the
table with it's just it's where you're
like you're like it's just you and the
bride like game of thrones and like
we're always with each other what the
[ __ ] is this it looks like somebody's
gonna go like this and somebody's just
gonna slit someone's throat yes that's
what we do at our wedding
we sit together and
and make sure that we are the [ __ ]
king that's [ __ ] if you do that you
sit with your friends dude you're here
with your friends it's a love fest
so um
and eric [ __ ] did it with his bride
he [ __ ] up dude i'm telling you you
want to sit with your friends man
and uh
so we sat and we were sitting down and
all of a sudden i get a tap on my
shoulder and there he is the [ __ ]
lead of the cowlings band he says hey
man dude i just and i knew it i knew
that's how he was gonna [ __ ] sound
because of his face sometimes you just
guess and you know right when i was a
kid i used to have this feeling that i
thought i would be able to predict who
the next person i was gonna see in my
life was oh dude i am crazy but i had
this strong feeling like a very strong
feeling that the next person i saw when
i was out whether i was at a mall or
turned a corner or whatever that i
should be able to see and know what he
was going to look like and of course i
never did it but i always tried but
voices i'm good dude one guy one time a
guy walked in a room uh and i was at ccd
communicate community communion and i
was with my brother and uh and he came
in and i was like oh that guy's gonna
sound like this and i did his voice and
then he [ __ ] started talking i was
like dude i knew him i was like how do
you do that and i go like this i got
powers man i got powers
so um
so the guy came in and started talking
and he was like dude
i just want to say how happy i am to be
here and i was like oh he's one of these
positive guys right like he's got to be
one of these [ __ ] yoga dudes he's got
to be one of these guys who eats a lot
of granola does yoga always is positive
and probably i'm not saying he did i
have no idea but probably has bad breath
right like guys who are super positive
and do yoga if you don't have bad breath
something's seriously wrong with you
you're not doing it right right you got
to have bad breath if you do yoga and
you're always
positive right
so um
so he comes up and he's just like dude
i'm so happy to be here man he's one of
these 55 year olds one of these 50 year
olds that talk says dude a lot you know
and uh i'm so great this is such a
beautiful time uh in in life and you're
you're getting married and uh i'm so
happy you hired us is there anything
that we can do that we can sing for you
guys that you'd like and i said oh dude
well we we saw your video and your demo
reel it and you killed it it's amazing
this is why we hired you i didn't tell
him he hired him because of his face
because you're obviously a wedding
singer and this is the guy i want
singing at my wedding because of his
face
because of the aesthetic of his
face
right
this guy goes move over adam sandler
with jerry curl i'll do it
right
so um i say you [ __ ] it kills you guys
are great just do what you do and he
said oh really you sure we could do a
sort of mix of stuff and normally what
we do is classic rock we play the
classics if that's cool and i was like
absolutely he was like so you don't want
anything specific you don't want to lead
me in a certain direction and i was like
nah dude you do you it's why we hired
you and that's something i believe in
dude it's something i believe in we had
a wedding planner and she said we were
the easiest couple that she ever [ __ ]
worked with
[Music]
because you delegate right we delegate
my babies we're all about delegation
that's why when you join the cult and
you share ideas
what do you do dude everyone has a
[ __ ] thing to do in the tall grass or
they're working on the cabin they're
putting out wheats
trimming some [ __ ] hanging up curtains
we gotta live baby
but we're all about delegating
this is delegating central right
and uh so we're so so i say you do you
and he says all right well if you change
your mind if you think anything i'm your
guy just come to me and i go all right
cool
and then he walks away and i see my
beautiful bride so i say hey you know
what guy who has that face why don't you
ask her she's she would know and i see
him
and then kristen just goes like this
and he's like
and she goes
and he goes like this
then walks away right
so i'm like all right he's just gonna
play the hits he's gonna do what we saw
in the video all right
and uh we get there the band is in full
swing and
it they are just [ __ ] killing it dude
flaming it up right okay
and so the guy's singing and oh he's
singing with his face just doing his
[ __ ] thing just killing it doing all
sorts of great songs songs where i'm
like well i even thought of that but
then okay okay yeah very cool
and um
the first set ends you know he does like
a 40-minute set or whatever it is he
said we're gonna come back for another
set we're gonna take a little break
he comes back
i'm [ __ ] talking and [ __ ] the music's
playing and all that [ __ ] i gotta tap on
my shoulder
who is it dude
it's the [ __ ] wedding singer and he
says hey man and i said hey he's like
dude i'm so happy i'm here and this is
great isn't it and i said yeah he said
dude is there anything that you want me
to sing for you and i was like oh man
dude honestly this night is going
spectacular and i'm just [ __ ] love
what you're doing he says all right
because if you want me to do any certain
things i mean you can give me a few
songs or whatever and i could play him
we know everything and i was like dude
honestly no notes you're killing it
everyone's having a good time i don't
want to interfere with it so please just
continue to do what you're doing and he
goes like this ah all right man well let
me know if you change your mind and i
said okay cool he puts his [ __ ] ear
things back in and he goes and kills
another set yes dude everyone's having a
good time they do another set and they
kill it dude this band they take [ __ ]
you you heard about spin moves in the
first set dude this guy was spinning so
hard he looked shorter by the end of the
second set because he was drilling a
hole into the ground dude this guy was
now just [ __ ] he looked short he was
like a con out there just [ __ ] kind
of music
getting [ __ ] small as [ __ ] dude
shout out to the old episode where i
made fun of akon he should be short
because of the [ __ ] voice he has
anyway dude for all the true babies they
know that [ __ ]
so does another set dude and this
[ __ ] they i thought the first set was
good and they are just
firing right
that setting we're going to take a break
because i was like three hours into the
[ __ ]
uh
dancing
i get a tap on my shoulder and i'm by
the by this time i'm sitting down my
legs are done like you know when you're
just working on adrenaline in vivants
and you're just like oh okay cool i had
no idea that my legs were moving this
much so long and now i gotta just take a
[ __ ] seat
and you sit down to somebody you barely
know and they're just like so
is it hard what you do and you're like
oh here we go
what do you mean dude it's not brain
surgery but
so uh how do i if i wanted to get into
stand up i you're 50. and so
so
i
who comes up to me the [ __ ] wedding
singer and this is three hours into him
already singing i mean the guy is
crushing it right and he says
oh man
this is just great what a vibe i'm so
happy i'm here and i'm like
still okay but i get it
and he's like
sure enough says you know what he's
gonna say but he actually says again for
the third time
is there anything you want me to play
and i'm like this guy
he really wants a suggestion okay but i
don't know
i'm not even i don't know what he played
or what he didn't play
so i say you know what man
i know you keep asking but you're
killing it i don't want to get in your
way of the [ __ ] you're just
on this mode of absolutely everyone's
having a good time play whatever it is
that you got if you got more [ __ ] you
want to play keep doing it do whatever
you want and he says are you sure man i
mean it's been a whole night and like if
you want you could tell now i'm like
does this guy think i'm like lying to
him like i do have a secret song that i
want him to play
that maybe i'm not saying because i'm
bashful
i'm not bashful
he should know i'm not bashful
i mean he's definitely googled me and
knows what i do hope he didn't google me
but like
so i'm like he's like are you sure
there's nothing and and i'm like all
right you know what dude it's been three
times
so now you win
you win
i'm gonna say a song
because everything's going right now
here in my head i'm gonna say a song
he's gonna say we don't know if we know
that oh okay and then he's gonna [ __ ] it
it's gonna be my fault right but i'm
like the guys come up to me three times
the night's almost over
so i say
okay
brick house
i haven't thought
of the song brick house
since i first saw pulp fiction and brick
house was on in the background of one of
the scenes
okay
i mean i haven't thought of the song
brick house
in decades
i don't know where i pulled this [ __ ]
title brick house out of
but i do like the song and that's where
my mind went so i said to the guy
brick house
and this is what he does now i gotta
stand up because this is what he did
this is what he did he he goes like this
i know you can't see me in my body but
this is what he does this is what he
does he goes like this
he goes like this
[Applause]
oh
man
that is great i am just so
happy i'm here thank you for having me
and i said
yeah man i'm really happy you're here
and he starts to walk away and as he's
walking away
he says
it feels so
good
why
what does okay he says it feels so good
and walks away so i was like man i
really nailed the suggestion
they do their set they play for another
hour the guy never [ __ ] played brick
house
the whole time you didn't play brick i
still live in her brick house now i
still haven't heard brick house
the guy [ __ ] asked me three times
monopolizing my conversation i'm giving
him my energy please please tell me a
song i finally pulled out brick house
because i heard it once in [ __ ] 1992
and the guy [ __ ] looked like he was
about to stroke me off with pride
and then didn't [ __ ] play it
how can you be like that
that guy
is my [ __ ] hero dude that is unreal
to do that
i love this dude god i would [ __ ]
hang out with that dude so much he yeah
dude i i feel so bad that i already had
my wedding i would invite him to my
wedding crazy
[Music]
crazy
[Music]